okay so the doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness trailer completely
blew the roof off the internet when it
dropped online last week the new teaser
was packed with alternate realities us
wondering who the big villain was gonna
be and america chavez in her best denim
battling denim at the heart of it though
is the voice of professor x played once
more by patrick stewart stewart has
since said in interviews and i'm not
lying here he said it just sounds like
someone who's doing an impression of him
and he's denied all involvement look the
guy is an amazing actor but i don't know
if i can go through the whole andrew
it's a photoshop garfield saga again
he's in the movie mutants are here and
whatever happens x gonna give it to you
he gonna give it to you because of this
we now know the fox merger happened for
a good reason and though it initially
seemed like disney buying the company
was to do the world's most expensive
boner joke we will be getting the x-men
back but what if mutants are already in
the mcu and we just don't know it well
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing our crazy theories on how
reality in the mcu might not be the same
as what we know i've wasted enough of
your time with some crap puns that you
wish you could forget and that kind of
takes us into the first theory i want to
talk about now i want you to dig deep
and try and remember someone you once
knew a boy called peter parker cast your
mind back to the end of spider-man no
home and you might remember that doctor
strange cast a forgetting spell that
erased the teenager from the minds of
everyone that ever met him this included
you and the entire population forgot he
was spider-man and though mutants on the
whole aren't magic they may have a
strong telepath at their core who can
pull off the same thing in x2 he watched
his professor x was tricked into using
cerebro as a weapon in order to make the
entire world ride in pain like they got
to see x-men origins wolverine early now
this showed that if probably configured
cerebral can get into the minds of the
entire planet and potentially professor
x could be hypnotizing the population to
make them forget that mutants exist this
is actually something that has
precedence in the films and at the end
of x-men first class we watched as a
young child made moira mctaggart forget
everything about their adventures
together he removed all the important
information from her memory so that she
couldn't tap into it and this was to the
point that she didn't even recognize him
in x-men apocalypse i do think that if
they wanted to bring the x-men into the
mcu that the best way to do it might be
to have them already there and the next
made everyone forget about it like the
new mutants movie
[Applause]
we already know that they face
prosecution and persecution at every
single stage and thus x making the world
forget about them would help out the
entirety of mutant kind if we go off the
fox franchise then mutants were pretty
much always in the firing line and even
magneto was blamed for the death of jfk
which added to the magic bullet theory
we know that disney have an x-men 97
cartoon coming soon and this could
potentially explore mutants in the mcu
and how they already exist we just can't
remember them now going after doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
trailer we know that the x we meet is
likely part of an alternate reality in
the multiverse however loki and what if
showed us that there exists alternate
versions of characters on almost every
single reality therefore if a version of
professor x exists in the ultronbot
dimension it makes sense that there'd be
one in the mcu timeline as well now
because of this we could have had a
small group of mutants on earth that
participated in many of the events we
watched unfold in the x-men movies
whether it's world war ii the cuban
missile crisis the last stand or any of
the other atrocities that were committed
in the fox franchise the mutants
involved may have simply been wiped from
the minds of everyone who could recall
the events now we have another big
theory coming up in just a bit but in
the meantime i'd love to hear your best
ones on what you think could be
happening as to thank you you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away a copy of june on the 28th
of feb just like the video make sure
you're subscribed and all the wonderful
riches of one blu-ray could be yours yay
now if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose dad
jokes are like wolverine because they
never get old without the way a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the rest of the video
okay so another theory that i think
would be absolutely mind-blowing is that
we've had mutants all along the
outskirts of reality and all that we've
witnessed in the mcu so far is actually
an illusion carried out by wander we
know from west view that she possesses
the ability to completely override
reality and create whatever she wants
trapping all inside of it if we look at
the comics namely the story house of m
we followed her as she completely
reroute the rules of the marvel universe
and built a world where she and her
family flourished in this alternate
dimension during the 70s magneto
revealed an anti-mutant conspiracy
involving richard nixon he was then
granted sovereignty and appointed the
leader of the mutants hence the name
house of m due to the attack on the
mutants they were also put forth as the
most important forms of life on the
planet but over time they start to run
everything and they look down on sapiens
who they saw as inferior the full world
had done a complete 180 with humans
being persecuted but for the mutants it
was great all the heroes pretty much
lived there hashtag best lives but was
an illusion and eventually they started
to come to the realization that
everything was fake layla miller was the
first of these and she slowly went to
the heroes and woke them about their
spell when all of the heroes were
together they ended up confronting
wonder and managed to defeat her at the
heart of this was doctor strange who had
a standoff with her at the end of the
book now judging by the multiverse of
madness trailer wander is the villain
and she very much discusses how she's
regarded as the enemy for warping
reality
you break the rules look up
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair there's also that
weird zombie shot of her from the tv
spot and in it we watch her fight what
looks like maria rambo as captain marvel
side tangent yeah i did a video saying
this was maria and got so many comments
saying this was clearly jonathan mages
kang everyone's saying it's definitely
iron lad but in the words of shakira
hips don't lie i've never seen a guy
with hips like that so yeah i'm pretty
sure it's maria at least i hope it is or
i'm gonna look pretty [ __ ] stupid
anyway back to the main point wonder is
clearly covered in blood and due to her
fighting in the lobby of the illuminati
base i'm guessing that she went rambo on
maria if it's her it might not be her
yeah it might not be her now she very
much appears to be the villain and this
could lead to strange confronting her at
the end of the movie after beating her
she could reveal that the entire mcu is
somewhat an illusion that has existed in
its own house of m pocket reality it's a
theory that has picked up a lot of steam
recently and though i don't agree with
it i thought it was worth bringing up as
it's doing numbers on tick-tock now what
this would mean is that mutants existed
on the outskirts of reality and they
potentially try to break into it and
pull strange out as he's the only one
who can stop wander this might explain
why wander is trying to destroy the
headquarters and why professor x says
this line
we should tell him the truth personally
though i don't really think that's true
but house of m could somewhat hint
towards what's going to be happening to
bring the mutants across the book ends
with wonder saying no more mutants and
this ends up wiping most of them off the
planet however the way that the movie
could go could somewhat pull from this
but add a comma in it if strange has
meant mutants in the alternate reality
and has seen what they've done to turn
their dimension into somewhat of a
fascist state you might want to stop
them from entering the mcu wonders kids
wicken and speeder mutants themselves
and when strange says that she can't
have them in the mc timeline she might
say no more mutants see add a little
comma after the no there and the phrase
takes a whole new meaning
[Music]
now this would stay true to the source
material allow strange to go and try and
stop her and also bring mutants in in a
cool way that references the comics
wonder finally getting her kids with a
comma would feel like karma and let's
just hope she doesn't go rogue and suck
the life out of strange go rogue one of
the worst jokes we've had in the video
ever but i just want to say a huge thank
you to all you guys for your support
over the last couple of days happy to
let you know that my wife had our twins
on friday and both she and the kids are
doing really well little james and harry
spoilers are probably gonna take over
the empire one day if you think i'm bad
just wait till you meet my kids some sad
news to end on though unfortunately
multiverse of madness was due to release
in less than three months but it's been
pushed back to june why's that well
that's because may is dead anyway that's
the video what a terrific audience and
thank you so much for sitting until the
end i've always liked you you know and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on how you think that mutants will be
brought into the mcu if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our insane details
breakdown on the multiverse of madness
trailer which will be linked on screen
right now we pointed out some of the
coolest things in it so definitely go
head over there right after this without
the way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see in the next one take
care peace